okay hi everyone
welcome to another episode of science
and technology
q a for kids and others
um all right i think we have a few
questions that
were left over from last
week um there's a question from the
chemist here
if humankind had evolved 12 fingers
if we all use base 12 to count and to do
commerce
would this have made any difference to
uh our scientific development
um okay let me uh
hold on the um just trying to organize
my screen here a little bit
you go hmm interesting question never
thought about that before
well you know let's talk about a little
bit of history so
the first sort of civilization that
really
uh at least that we know about that
really developed
numerical kinds of things in a very
serious way with the babylonians
about four thousand years ago um kind of
the first time there had been
serious cities and things had to be
organized and people needed records and
they needed to have
ways to decide about
commercial things and taxation things
and all those kinds of things
the babylonians used base 60. that's how
we ended up having 60 minutes in an
hour probably also 60 seconds in a
minute
um they had a a somewhat more
elaborate version of um
oh questions like how many days in a
year things like that but they had a
they had a base 60 system and um
they knew about lots of kinds of things
in math actually
we just recently uh sort of finished off
doing some math exercises that were on
one of these babylonian tablets
from maybe 3000 years ago that were
presumably school exercises at that time
sort of latest technology um i think
back in the day
probably the babylonians could only work
out the answers approximately but but we
can now do it
exactly and so on but in any case the um
uh dublin is
about lots of kinds of things some
things they didn't know about for
example they didn't know about decimals
so
numbers you know 2.7564
et cetera et cetera they didn't know
about that idea of having
fractional parts of numbers like that
instead all they knew about was ratios
of numbers so they would say
you know it's two plus one sixtieth or
two
plus two sixtieths and so on um
and that's a perfectly good way to deal
with numbers um it gives you a little
bit of a different
idea about which numbers are important
relative to
uh numbers like decimals where it's like
you can put any sequence of digits after
the decimal points to get
to specify a number so for example in
the babylonians had this way of doing
things with with base 60
they were very concerned with
reciprocals one over certain numbers
how that could be expressed the
egyptians i think even more so there are
these things that these days get called
egyptian fractions
which is can you write a number as
something like 1 over 2
plus 1 over 7 plus 1 over 9 plus
whatever
you can write any number uh like that
as a sum of reciprocals actually there
isn't even a unique way to do it there
can be several ways to do it
um and that's a different way to write
numbers and that's
it's kind of a the the one of the issues
is you say well there isn't a unique way
to do it and that's
a troublesome thing in terms of dealing
with numbers if you've got two numbers
and somebody hands you one of them is
represented in terms of 1 7th 1 19th one
blah blah blah
and another one is represented some
other way and you don't know those
numbers don't look the same so you can't
immediately tell those numbers
are the same number whereas if you have
decimals 1.27
or whatever that particular sequence of
digits
that represents a particular number and
there's only one way to represent that
number
well actually a little footnote there
which is very important for mathematics
higher mathematics is
the number 0.99999999999 going on
forever
is really kind of the same number as
1.000
there's there's when you make that
sequence of nines as
infinitely long it's like you're
infinitely close to the next number up
which is 1.000
and that identification of numbers like
that causes all kinds of issues in
in higher mathematics but any case
back in babylonian times the kind of the
idea was it's rational numbers
ratios of things ratios to something
over 60 and so on
that was the story all the time so for
example
when they made square root tables uh
some numbers what one of the discoveries
uh uh often attributed to pythagoras
is a discovery that um you can't
that something like the square root of
two cannot be written as a rational
number
you see what when squared when
multiplied by itself is equal to two
the answer is one point four one four
blah blah blah blah blah blah infinite
sequence of digits
there's no way to write the square root
of two
as a ratio of two numbers it's not equal
to you know
11 over 7 or something it's it's it's
it's a number that cannot be expressed
as a ratio of two whole numbers and
there was a discovery that uh
was actually is said to have been very
disappointing to pythagoras
because he kind of had this idea that um
uh in the world there should only be
these nice
ratios of things but yet square root of
two which is something easy to construct
didn't have that feature well when the
babylonians made square root tables
uh because they only had rational
numbers as a way to represent things
when they got to a number that didn't
couldn't be expressed in terms of
rational numbers
they just left that space blank in the
square root table
so they didn't have a way to express it
so that that's a
sort of a downer to the idea of
everything is represented as a rational
number when you have something that
isn't
it's like how do you express it you
don't have a good way to express it
uh the um the idea
of decimal numbers or you know this idea
that you can have numbers after a
decimal point
that works even if you're using
something other than base
10. so normally we just use 10 digits
comes from our 10 fingers i think the
question here was about what if we had
12 fingers we might use
base 12 we'd be counting you know
one two three four five six seven eight
nine and instead of going to one
zero we would go after nine we'd
probably have something
in modern hexadecimal it's usually a
then that would be
represent a digit for 10 a digit for 11
and 12 what we call 12
would then be 1 0 in basis 12.
so but in any base you can have this
idea
of uh writing fractional numbers as
point
and then the uh uh then success of uh
uh um you know one tenth one hundredth
one thousandth etc that could be one
1 12 squared 1 12 1 12 cubed and so on
um but uh that idea of decimal numbers
which seems completely obvious to us now
of of numbers with decimals
you know numbers with decimal points and
so on that number didn't
that idea didn't arise until the
beginning of the 1600s
so it was that number that idea even
though people have been using numbers
for thousands of years
and have worked out all kinds of
mathematics around numbers the idea that
you could write out a number
as the sequence of of of uh of
fractional digits like that didn't arise
for a long time
um you know is there a um uh
there are other ways to represent
numbers other than the ones that we use
so
we normally use positional notation you
know a number where
there's a a units column a tens column a
hundreds column whatever
instead of using base 10 for positional
notation we could use base 12
or we'd have you know 1 12 12 square 144
i don't know what 12 cubed is i'd have
to work that out um
the uh we can also you know computers
like using base two
where the digits are just one or zero so
the um there's the units
then the two's column fours column
eights sixteen thirty two et cetera et
cetera
um these are but these are all uh
notations for numbers
that are basically uh use
uh a number is equal to some sum of
powers of some particular thing but
there are other ways to represent
numbers
um uh one that's a little bit elaborate
maybe i won't explain in detail is a
thing called continued fractions
um where you say that a number is one
over one plus one over
it's a big long you show it on on
write it down it's a it's kind of fun to
write down because it's a very built up
fraction of many many layers of built up
fraction continued fractions
have all kinds of nice properties about
the ways that you can do arithmetic with
them and so on
and the ways that um that numbers
combine with them that are much better
than what you get
with positional notation where you have
to have all kinds of carry digits when
you do arithmetic on them and so on
so anyway i think there are this
question about
sort of how you represent numbers and is
that important
in uh in the development of of science
there definitely a ways that this can
have an effect i'm not sure about base
12 versus base 10
that one's less clear to me i'll give
you an example of an interesting piece
of science history
related to the representation of numbers
so back in
in roman times numbers were represented
with the roman numerals
and um uh the you know roman numerals
are things like you know there's a big i
for one there's a big v for five there's
a big x for ten
all those kinds of things and um one
feature
of numbers at that time is numbers were
represented by letters
same thing was done in greek numerals
greek numerals they actually used this
sequence of letters in their alphabet
alphabetical gamma
etc as one two three etc um
but in any case the basic point was
numbers are represented by letters
okay so then let's say you're going to
be trying to do something like algebra
in algebra we're used to using letters
to represent variables unknowns like x
and so on
well they kind of didn't have a way to
do that because they kind of didn't
have the idea that you could distinguish
numbers
from things standing for numbers it's
pretty obvious to us today
but that wasn't an obvious thing and the
fact that they had numbers that were
written
in terms of letters kind of really
slowed that down
and it was only when hindu arabic
numerals
came to the west basically around 1200
a.d
that um this idea even could emerge
of being able to have letters that stand
for numbers and it wasn't it was in the
1400s vietnam people
started inventing algebra and had this
notation for
for variables standing for numbers i
think it was descartes who
who um in the 1600s who um uh
introduced this x the ubiquitous you
know x is the unknown variable
um he'd been using uh from the early
part of the alphabet abc he's been using
those letters
to represent fixed things and then he
was like going from the other end of the
alphabet
to um to represent variable things
things where you didn't know what the
what the value was yet and i think i
think it's it's said that
um back in those days i mean uh that
when he was getting books printed and so
on
that z's at least um in
uh in france and the places and
and um uh the parts of europe where
where descartes hung out
um the um uh
the the um z's were very uncommon and so
if you wanted to get your book printed
you know the printers will be up in arms
they'd say we don't have any z
characters you know what are you using
all these z characters for so he decided
not to use
even though he had this kind of idea use
the end of the alphabet to represent
unknown things
he decided stay away from the z's there
aren't enough of those that printers
i i just to explain this point uh you
know
back in the day right printing was done
by having little pieces of lead
that were in the shapes of letters that
you would assemble
in a in rows and then you would use that
as a as a thing to actually you know
print your book and so it mattered how
many physical
z's or x's or something had been made
they were usually in these wooden
um boxes you know the in modern times we
talk about uppercase letters
that was because there used to be these
two cases uh
wooden cases that um the upper case had
the capital letters the lower case had
the
um had the small letters um and that was
that was how you would do um uh you do
type setting by pulling out these pieces
of lead type
okay how do i know this well because
when i was a kid
though that technology was still extant
and i even
uh used um i guess it's called
letterpress these days the small
small press things um i uh in
my early as a high school kid in
my early efforts at advertising things
often involved
making printed uh flyers which i
would print using a uh that kind of
letterpress printing press thing
and you actually had to take the pieces
of lead type and arrange them in these
in these little trays and um you know
it's always fun to see that the you know
the ease
box of type was always bigger than the
than the x's
box of type because there are more e's
in typical english than x's and so on
anyway that's the
little bit of the origin of the the x
for the unknown variable
all right we have lots of interesting
questions here okay
um the uh
it's a question from promenities asking
about some
uh dana scott and looking forward
looking backward
um that's interesting i i literally
just interacted with dana this week so
that's a that's a um uh
interesting thought um okay
um
gosh all right lots of questions here
um this question from heposu um
in our physics project we imagine that
the universe emerges from a simple set
of rules the question is
could the legal system emerge from a
simple set of rules
interesting question i think the answer
is no
let me try to explain the
in physics what we say is there's some
little rule
and you apply the rule you apply it
again you apply it again
the rule is building something it's
generating a thing maybe it's generating
our whole universe
that's one sort of way you can use rules
the other way you can use rules is as
constraints
to say this is what should happen we'll
only allow things to happen
when they follow this rule that's more
what happens in mathematics in
mathematics
it's often you're given a set of
constraints this thing obeys this
equation this thing has this property
then what can exist that has those
properties so in other words in kind of
the way we think about the
the universe in our physics project it's
like given these rules just run the
rules and build something
whereas in doing mathematics and in the
legal system
it's more a question of we've got these
rules these can think rules constrain
how things can work
okay so the question then is what's the
interplay between these things
can you have if you want the world to be
a certain way
can you uh write down constraints
that for which which will make the world
be
just this way and not another way not
some way that oh we didn't think of that
we didn't want that
in other words can you have a simple set
of constraints that leads to the outcome
you want
that sort of force the outcome you want
well
the answer is it's really hard and let
me explain why
the reason is in this you just generate
everything from rules
you can start with these very simple
rules and you can end up producing very
complicated behavior
uh you can generate behavior that sort
of
seems irreducibly complicated you know
you might think
you start with simple rules you'll
always get simple behavior well you
don't
you can start with some simple rules and
you'll get extremely complicated
behavior which is
kind of what we think is happening in
the universe we have these simple rules
yet we have the whole universe with all
the complexity
that the universe shows so then you say
well
i want to for example let me give a
practical example
i want to build an ai an artificial
intelligence
and i want to give that artificial
intelligence ethical principles
and i want to tell the artificial
intelligence
operate in these ways and not others i
want to give you constraints on how you
should operate
that's similar to the operation of the
legal system except in this case it
would be
because it's operating on an ai it's not
sort of telling people what to do
it's having an ai that has a code inside
it
which it will just follow that it's a
little bit better to find so you can say
okay um you know what what do you put
into the ai to make it work the way you
want it
and not any way that you might not want
it okay
so the problem is that it
is kind of an inevitable feature that
you know you put in these constraints
you say i want it to do this i want to
do that i want to do the other thing
there is no and a little bit harder to
explain but basically
uh to force some particular form of of
behavior
that where okay if the thing
is operating in a world where there is
computational irreducibility where
complicated things can happen
it is inevitable that there is no simple
set of constraints
that will uh always ensure
that sort of nothing unexpected ever
happens
uh how to explain this the um i mean
in a sense it it it requires going into
a little bit of
kind of the foundational theory of
computation
um and a bunch of things i've figured
out at various times
um to explain just how this works um let
me mention an analogy
uh in the mathematics case one of the
things you might want to say
uh maybe a hundred and thirty years ago
people said we're going to write down a
set of axioms
which are going to define how numbers
work they're going to define arithmetic
they're going to say for all numbers x
and y x plus y is the same as y
plus x for all numbers blah blah blah
this and this and this is true
okay so there's a set of axioms that you
you might say
describe features of numbers well what
people originally thought is
there's a set of axioms and they
describe numbers nothing
can exist in this sort of artificial
world except
the numbers that we're used to whole
numbers whatever else
okay well that all looked good until
1931
when kurt gerdel came along with his
girls theorem
uh idea in which he showed that
basically
what you got by by these axioms
you could never constrain yourself to
get just the integers just the whole
numbers and nothing but the whole
numbers
that if any finite set of axioms would
always have the property
that would always be there will always
be some unexpected thing that was also
consistent with those axioms
some unexpected consequence something
that yes it officially obeys those
axioms but it doesn't really
obey them so that's a feature of
girdle's theorem
uh that in addition to ordinary integers
there can be so-called non-standard
arithmetics
which are incredibly weird but
nevertheless still obey those accents
you can say let's patch it up let's add
more axioms let's try and
uh make it so that we're constraining
things more well you'll never be able to
do that with any finite number of axioms
okay so fast forward to modern times and
um
i'll give you an example of how that
manifests in practice
so there's a blockchain called ethereum
which is a a cryptocurrency
uh a purely digital currency that
operates
according to a certain set of rules that
are encoded in basically programs
well a few years a couple years ago
three years ago now maybe
there was an attempt to have a an
investment fund
that was going to be based on ethereum
and it was
something called the dao um not the dao
do w
not the dao um d-a-o
the it was an attempt to make something
that would be a distributed autonomous
organization it was an attempt to make
something where
the laws the rules for this organization
the legal rules for this organization
were purely defined in code there was no
no human was going to be involved
nothing was going to nothing was going
to be
be there except the code
and seemed like a good idea seems like
what could possibly go wrong
well what went wrong is somebody found a
way to
uh use the code that was there
to pay themselves 50 million dollars and
everybody said you can't do that
that's not what you know this this was
an investment fund for
investing in whatever you can't just pay
yourself 50 million dollars from it
but the person i think said uh
you know well look it's just you know
it's all operating according to code
um and what they did satisfies the
constraints defined by the code
so well but that wasn't what the intent
of the code was well but that's not what
the point is
you're saying is there a set of rules
that you can write down that's just in
the code
that represents what should happen um
well in the end what happened was
that uh there was sort of a fork made of
of um
uh of ethereum in which them uh the um
uh the set of people some people said
we're just going to ignore
the fact that we said everything was
going to operate according to code we're
just going to come in
and change everything ourselves just by
hand
and other people said no no let's let's
let it operate according to the code
and uh and this person will run off with
some money that they shouldn't otherwise
we don't think they should have as
humans should have had but the code said
they could do it so it has to be okay
i think i i haven't looked recently but
but um the relative value of these two
forks
the one where people just came in and
changed it was vastly more valuable than
one where they just let the code run
so that's a sort of practical example of
of the attempt to sort of write down
essentially computational rules
that say how the world should work in
the end
this question of you know can there be a
simple set of rules that
are sort of the the core of the law
the answer is i don't think it works i
don't think that the
the thing where you have constraints
that produce behavior you want
i don't think you can do that in a sort
of finite way and and you see that in
you know in legal systems there are you
know the us for example has a
constitution
and uh which is sort of defines the core
of its legal system but then there are
endless precedents that get added for
specific cases
about what do you do if blah blah blah
blah blah
i think it is inevitable i think it's
essentially a mathematical inevitability
that you will always have this what do
you do in the case of blah blah blah
blah blah
and there isn't really a a kind of a a
core
sort of simple rule that you can give
where you just say follow this rule and
all be good
i mean this this has come up a lot in
recent times
in things like ai ethics in questions
like
if you're ranking results that people
are going to be showing you're trying to
decide
you know which results should be removed
because they're
they're bad in some way or another you
know what's the rule for doing that is
there's some sort of golden rule that
you can use
which is just some simple principle
where you just follow that
and you work out its consequences it
will be good i don't think it works that
way i don't think that's possible
i think that um in a sense the um
what is possible is given a set of sort
of human values you can
you can make an attempt to capture those
but there will always be sort of things
that happen in the world
where you haven't quite defined how
those values will cover that particular
case uh at least that's that's that's my
my view of it um
let's see
[Music]
it's a um here from uh
mahmoud uh
about imaginary numbers and how they
manifest in real life
and implementing quantum logic circuits
okay let me that's a bit of a
challenging one let me let me see what i
can do for that
so okay so ordinary numbers the ones we
count with one two three four five
people sort of understand how those work
took a long time in the history of
the development of mathematics before
people even understood
zero to be a meaningful number and
it was i think 1400s before people
understood um that negative numbers
were a useful thing to think about minus
one minus two minus three
it's like numbers one two three four
five if you're counting
apples or sheep or something you can
have five of them
but what does it mean to have minus five
sheep you have to have kind of a bigger
story around what you're doing it's like
well i owe you five sheep so
i count as having minus five sheep and
by the time you're doing these sort of
more abstract accounting kinds of things
negative numbers start making sense
um when you're trying to solve
mathematical problems they can make
sense to introduce
well okay so if we're in the solving
mathematical problems
here's um here's a mathematical question
so
we can say 2 times 2 is 4. 3 times 3
is 9. let's say we're given 9 and we're
asked
what times what is equal to 9
what is the the the square root of 9
so 9 we can say okay the answer is three
all good
um any positive number we can say the
answer is whatever it is
all good okay what happens if we have a
negative number like minus one
what when multiplied by itself is equal
to minus one
you think about it it's like well minus
one times minus one is plus one
so how do we make something when where
the thing
times itself is equal to minus one so
back in in the 1500s i guess
a chap called cardano was famous for
having
having said in order to in his
particular case solve cubic equations
um we will have to introduce this thing
which has the property that the thing
times itself is equal to minus one
and that thing got called i and that
thing that
thing called i is an imaginary number
it's a number
that uh it's it's um
it's just a number that has the property
that the thing
i times itself is equal to minus one you
can build up a whole system of numbers
you can say
something like three plus i which is the
number three
plus uh or three plus two i so number
three
plus two times the square root of minus
one and you can kind of think of the
ordinary numbers
as being one set of things and the
imaginary numbers being another set of
things and
we can think about them as we can draw
them as coordinates we can say
along the horizontal axis where we're
plotting uh the value of the
real part and along the imaginary axis
the
along the the vertical axis the
imaginary part so 3 plus 2i would just
be a point
in this uh plane where we're saying we
go three units
along horizontally and two units up and
that's 3 plus 2i or we could say
1 minus seven i will be one unit uh
horizontally and seven units
down um in um uh in the imaginary
direction
so so in a sense complex numbers which
are numbers that have both a real part
and an imaginary part
you can just think of complex numbers as
being like pairs of ordinary numbers
there's the real part of the number
and the imaginary part of the number um
why is this useful
it's useful for a zillion different
purposes it's particularly useful
because a lot of equations
can be uh it's the the fundamental
theorem
of algebra is that a polynomial equation
a
equation involving you know squares
cubes whatever
powers of numbers that says x cubed plus
x squared minus 3x equals 7 or something
an equation like that any such equation
can be solved
using complex numbers that is there
exists a value of x
that is a complex number where you fill
it into that equation you work out the
equation of the equation is correct
so that's the that's why complex numbers
that's one of the reasons complex
numbers show up all over the place is
because they let you solve
any equation involving polynomials there
a lot of other reasons why complex
numbers are useful they're a good way
to sort of when you've got a pair of
numbers often things work out so that
you can represent them well
as a complex number and there are there
are rules for arithmetic with complex
numbers and so on and so on and so on
okay what does that have to do with
quantum mechanics
so quantum mechanics is the theory of
how sort of very small things work like
electrons and so on
it's sort of the the the what happens
when you're not dealing with large-scale
objects like
marbles or something where you can just
see the object and it does a definite
thing
in quantum mechanics you're dealing with
what do individual electrons do
and what they do is something more
complicated than what large-scale
objects do
and in fact in our physics project we
have finally i think
got to a point where we actually begin
to understand how quantum mechanics
really works
and what's happening in quantum
mechanics is instead of a definite thing
happening
sort of a a collection of all possible
things happen
let me give you an example actually very
recent example which i've been figuring
out
how the analogy really works if you play
tic-tac-toe
what in the country i came from it's
called naughts and crosses
game you know x's and o's or whatever on
a
on on a piece of paper okay so you start
off you've got a blank board
you put down an x somewhere somebody
else puts down an o
somewhere keep going eventually somebody
wins the game or whatever
but imagine the set of all possible
games you started from the blank thing
and you could put the x in any one of
nine positions
then you can put the o in any one of
eight positions and so on
at each step there's many possible
positions you can make up this whole
uh graph network that shows you start
from this
initial condition where it's just blank
you you have these nine choices then you
have like eight choices from each of the
nine choices
you keep going it turns out in that
particular game i think there's
5 741 i think that's right
uh possible uh possible configurations
of the game
possible ways that uh you can have put
put down x's and o's and so on in the
different steps of the game
but so in the game there are all these
different possibilities that could
happen that's a little bit like how
quantum mechanics works
that quantum mechanics allows you all
those different possibilities
but then when we're paying attention to
what's happening all we notice is
who won or who lost the game of
tic-tac-toe so to speak
we don't we don't kind of look inside at
all those different paths and how all
those paths worked
okay but it turns out that the way of
of figuring out uh the chance that one
person wins the game or the other person
wins the game
or in quantum mechanics the chance that
the electron goes this way rather than
that way
those chances are conveniently worked
out in terms of complex numbers
and actually you can kind of see a
little bit how that might work
how that works imagine you do you have
your tic-tac-toe thing
imagine you have this network so you
have a dot
for every possible configuration of the
tic-tac-toe board you join it to
all the dots all the configurations that
uh can be reached from that one by one
move in tic-tac-toe and you you make
this whole network of how that works
well it turns out in the world of our
physics project it turns out
that if you look at kind of the the the
set of
all possible configurations that you
could have reached after let's say three
steps of tic-tac-toe
you've got all these different
possibilities and that forms
what we call a branchial space a space
of branches because there are all these
different
branches that you could have taken of
doing one movement tic-tac-toe
versus another movement tic-tac-toe and
so on and that
so in this and that that space of
possible tic-tac-toe moves
you can think of it as being something
where all these different possible
tic-tac-toe boards
possible tic-tac-toe moves they're
arranged somehow how are they arranged
well you can think about them arranged
in a little bit like
ordinary space but the way that that
is arranged is something mathematically
different
and it turns out it looks like complex
numbers are really important in
describing how that's arranged
and in quantum mechanics the usual
description of quantum mechanics deeply
involves complex numbers
and uh we think that's sort of how they
arise
is by this description of this thing
that isn't an ordinary kind of space
that you can kind of move around and
we're used to moving around physical
space
but it's the space of different possible
configurations
not actually of tic-tac-toe but of sort
of the innards of what's
inside electrons and things like that
but the tic-tac-toe thing is an analogy
to that
so um the the idea
in the way complex numbers enter quantum
mechanics
um when you think about making a
computer with quantum mechanics one of
the big things that you might imagine
is that you can use all these different
parts like a standard computer
it's just like you ask it to compute
something it'll just go chunk
chunk and compute to the answer but if
you allowed
it to operate with quantum mechanics you
might say instead of just going chunk
chunk to one answer it would branch out
into all these parallel threads
where it could be trying different
things and then
hopefully merging them together later
but like you could be running
all the games of tic-tac-toe
simultaneously rather than just having
your computer just go through
i'm going to do this particular game so
the the way that that works is um
uh you're kind of using this branchial
space you're having things be at
different places in branch hill space
and that all links up with with uh with
complex numbers and actually
the mathematics of how this works we're
just figuring this out right now
um and it's it's very cool and i could
get very
elaborate and mathematical and talk
about it but let me not do that here
um
let's see okay
oh boy so many questions you guys are
all right there's a question from
crow is pi
irrational because we use the decimal
system
um and uh
is there a system sort of where it would
be rational the answer is no
there is no uh there's no
system based on whole numbers where
pi would be a rational number in other
words if we represent a number
like we do in base 10 where the number
735
is 5 plus
3 times 10 plus 7 times 10 squared
that that way of representing a number
by
a sum of of digits multiplied by
powers of the base uh if that base
is a whole we don't get to represent
pi like that and by the way when you're
doing fractional numbers
it's it's one over ten one over a
hundred plus well over a thousand etc
etc etc
um so with with a with whole number base
pi cannot be represented that way
now tricky thing if you allowed yourself
to use a fractional base
like what if you used the number pi as a
base
well then obviously you can represent uh
pi
pi is the equivalent of 10 of 1 0
in base pi so to speak um
now would base pi work out how would pi
base pi work out
so um we could say well let's take this
number
and represent it as pi plus pi square
plus
something times pi plus something times
pi squared plus something times pi cubed
and so on and so on and so on
okay you might say that's a that's a
great scheme well okay here's the
problem
problem is in base 10 we say we're just
going to use digits 0 through 9.
as soon as we get to digit above 9 we
say that's
that's in the next column that's a tens
column thing
um okay if we have base pi
we don't get to do that because it's not
like we're saying there's a set
of whole number digits that we can use
up to pi
we could say one two three and then
we'll we'll punt at three and then
if it's bigger than three we say it's pi
plus something else
um and so on um we don't get to that
there's no so
it will turn out i'm pretty sure that
there's no unique way to represent a
number in base pi
that is that there isn't it isn't the
case that there's
a unique set of of digits that we would
give
to specify the number we would have two
numbers which are in fact equal
and and by the way if we were trying to
represent integers in base pi
they would have infinite uh decimal
expansions
uh or infinite pi el expansions in base
pi infinite
infinite things to the right of the pi
eo point the analog of the decimal point
um and uh but in any case we we would
find out
that the numbers you know for two for
example
there'd be an infinite number of
representations and so somebody hands
you one of these things and says
uh have you seen this before you said
might say no but actually it's just two
it's just a different way to represent
two
so there are other ways to represent
numbers so for example
uh i mentioned continued fractions
before um
it turns out that some numbers um square
root
square root of two if you write it out
as decimal it just keeps on going
forever it never repeats
only the rational numbers repeat that
decimal expansion
um so you know square root of two is one
point four one four
dot dot dot dot you'd go on for millions
of digits pi
is the same way it never repeats it's
it's um
uh it's decimal expansion um but
in there are other ways to represent
these numbers where you do get
a more orderly sort of representation so
continued fractions
square roots uh are repeating continued
fractions just like
rational numbers are repeating decimals
square roots are repeating continued
fractions pi
is not a repeating continued fraction pi
has a very weird continued fraction
um that uh has all kinds of weird pieces
in it but it doesn't repeat
but um you can have other i think
there's a representation
involving uh iterated nested square
roots
in which pi does have a simple
representation
but um it's what tends to happen is in
any one of these sort of potential
representations you have sort of this
trade-off
of which numbers get represented easily
which numbers are hard to represent
is there uniqueness in the way you
represent numbers and when you're doing
an operation how difficult does it do
that operation how much
how many how many pieces of the number
do you have to update
to deal with that operation
um
let's see it's a question from jagabus
how much do i trust current methods of
encryption
leaving quantum computers aside are they
really unbreakable
well so
um encryption is about you take piece of
text
and you say i'm going to
do an operation on this piece of text
using a key
the key might be a password of some kind
and i'm going to grind up this text in
something that looks completely random
and it's only going to be ungrindable if
you use
that same key again if you know that
password
okay so how do people do that kind of
grinding right now
um actually i invented a technique for
doing this back in the 1980s
that is based on very simple uh
computational rule
this thing called rule 30 where you
essentially are generating the key
is the initial condition for rule 30 you
generate this sequence of apparently
random
things that you can use to uh
to randomize your text well
uh nobody knows how to break this
encryption scheme nobody knows how to go
from the the randomly encrypted thing to
figure out what the key was
um and uh in fact
if we knew the answer we would know the
answer to some very interesting
mathematical problems
which i suspect their answer is
in fact i put up a prize recently for
anybody who could get even part of the
way
to answering the question of whether
they're either proving that there isn't
regularity or finding regularity
in the sequence gender by rule 30. now
in practice encryption that's done uh
usually has two stages there's
there's usually a piece that's so-called
public key encryption
that's based on uh properties of um
of prime numbers and so on and then
there's a piece that's
uh usually based on um
what was really an earlier idea in
encryption uh so
my little rule 30 thing is a very simple
to describe
scheme for encryption you just follow
this rule you get a random sequence of
bits
use that random sequence of bits to to
randomize your message
um there are standard kind of encryption
things aes whatever it is
encryption there's also standard methods
they're a bit complicated you look at
their specification and what they do is
they say
take your message break it up into
blocks
uh take this sequence of bits in the
block replace it by this other sequence
of bits
permute the bits around in this
particular arrangement
and uh um and um and then
uh you know keep doing that a bunch of
times okay
as a matter of fact the when those
methods were originally invented in the
1950s
uh some of the mathematics was sort of a
similar precursor to some mathematics
that's been done with cellular automata
it was always very mysterious actually
um in the 1960s and so on when a
particular thing called the data
encryption standard
was developed in the us um it was always
very mysterious
why was it you know it's this weird
collection of you
you take replace this block with this
you permute the things around you do
this you do that
why and the so-called s boxes the
substitution boxes of des are a big
mystery
why why were those s boxes used actually
it seems like the mathematics of them
came out of mathematics that was done
for sort of precursors
of cellular automata and that's sort of
why those particular
choices were made but nobody was told at
the time why they were made
so uh but the the current methods for
doing some large-scale encryption
mostly work using these same kind of
block cipher substitution permutation
type ideas
and they're kind of messy and do we know
for certain that there's no way to be
very clever
and and sort of work backwards in these
things no we don't
no we don't and and those same methods
are used in in for example blockchains
where people are trying to proof the
work they say find
a thing which when encrypted gives a
bunch of zeros in it
so in other words you're saying find
something where you you know find the
key so to speak
so that when you run it through this
encryption thing you'll get a bunch of
zeros
and the only way it seems like that that
can be done
is it's a it's a a one-way function you
can just you just run it
from the input to the output you can't
go back the other way
can we prove that no we can't it's it's
really not
for certain it's something that uh
you know people bash bashed it from time
to time and
always managed to to crack it but we
don't have a theoretical proof that it's
not possible
now with public key cryptography that's
not
used for very large scale kind of
encrypt
gigabytes of data it's used particularly
for encrypting
key doing one level of encryption of
keys dealing with the management of uh
you have part of the key somebody else
has part of the key et cetera et cetera
et cetera
that's usually um uh things like
1024 2048 bits this kind of length
rather than gigabytes of data it's not
really fast enough to do
gigabytes of data directly with that
public key cryptography
is based on most often on
so-called rsa algorithm is based most
often on the fact that
it's much harder to factor a number to
say that
i don't know pick a number 90 is equal
to
9 times 10 then it is well let's say 56
is equal to 7 times 8.
it's much harder to figure out that 56
is equal to 7 times 8
than it is to multiply 7 by 8 and get
56.
and it's believed that the problem of
factoring a number
is that there's no much faster way to do
it
than essentially just trying the
different possible factors and seeing
what you get actually there are ways
that are considerably faster than that
but they're not uh they don't allow you
to just
read in the bits of the number and and
uh immediately
tell you uh what the factors of the
number are so
that's what the security of of uh
standard public key cryptography is
based on
that problem is thought to be hard but
nobody knows for sure that it's hard
the reason people think it might
definitely be hard is it's
it's close to so-called np-complete
problems
so np-complete problems have the feature
that
imagine you have a general computer any
kind of computer
um there are problems where if you are
told the answer you can check its right
quite quickly
but if you're not told the answer you
might have to go try a lot of possible
answers to see whether it's right
np stands for non-deterministic
polynomial time
and the non-deterministic means you just
get to guess things a lot of times and
see whether they're right and so what's
believed
is that there are so there are problems
that have the feature that
uh if you can solve that problem in
polynomial time quickly
then you can solve all np problems in
polynomial time
so there are problems known that have
that feature uh famous ones are things
like um
uh satisfiability and the traveling
salesman problem so satisfiability
is given an expression like p and q
or r and not p et cetera et cetera et
cetera
some logic expression like that can you
find values of p and q and so on
like p is true q is false r is true etc
so that the whole expression is true
you can certainly find the answer if
somebody shows you p
is p is true r is false etc etc etc
you can substitute those values into the
the expression you were given and you
can quickly say oh yeah i can check that
it's true
but to find out whether it's true you
might have to try all the
exponentially many possibilities for
true false true false et cetera et
cetera
um that's a problem that is known to be
np complete
in the sense that if you could solve
that problem quickly
then you could solve all other np
problems quickly
and uh it's believed that it's not
possible to do that people have tried
all sorts of different np problems and
tried to
uh try to see whether they can crack
them and haven't been able to
now factoring the problem for which is
used as the basis for public key
photography
is not known to be mp complete um it is
it might be but it is not known to be um
and so
to the to if even if we could prove that
mp complete problems couldn't be solved
quickly
we don't absolutely prove that factoring
can't be solved quickly and it's not
absolutely for certain that factoring
can't be solved quickly
one of the interesting challenges is to
make an encryption system that is based
on an mp complete
problem nobody has been able to do that
yet my rule 30 system
generalizations of it are mp complete
whether
them cryptographically is mp complete
whether
uh whether rule 30 in particular is
np-complete is not known
um but that uh and even if something
and the question of whether you can
solve an mp-complete problem in
quickly in polynomial time it's the
so-called p equals np problem
in computational complexity theory and
that problem is really hard
and nobody knows the answer to whether
that's possible actually some things
that have come out of our physics
project
give a kind of a way to think about that
problem that's a bit different than
and has existed before where you're kind
of thinking about the space of all
possible
uh computing because place of all
possible algorithms that could do things
and you can sort of represent that as a
as a structure in a kind of space
and you end up with this kind of ball of
possible places you can get to with
np with non-deterministic polynomial
time computation
and then specific polynomial time
computations are particular threads
within this kind of ball of possible
places you can get to and so there are
sort of geometrical questions about
where you can
get that might allow us to make progress
on the p versus mp problem
by the way it's quite possible that the
p versus mp problem
depends on uh what axioms you use for
your mathematics whether whether you
conclude one thing or the other so
maybe a very squiggly complicated thing
but anyway the original question was
uh how how much should one trust
cryptography that exists
today the answer is pretty much
but you know could we do we absolutely
know
from from mathematics and so on that
it's unbreakable we do not
um uh do i think that quantum mechanics
is going to make it easier to break
i actually don't think so um that's been
a recent discovery from our physics
project because we now understand a lot
more about quantum mechanics
so we can say what's possible to do and
what's not possible to do
and my guess is that it is not possible
to to
solve mp complete problems in polynomial
time with with quantum mechanics even
though there's sort of an indication
that at least the factoring problem can
be solved quickly but i don't think it's
correct
i think that it's one of these cases
where inside the quantum computer it
might know something
but for us to find out what it said will
take as much time as it would have taken
to do the the original factoring problem
it's kind of like
imagine you you've got your game of
tic-tac-toe and something's happened
inside the game
but you don't know what happened until
somebody wins or loses
um the uh the question is if you
you say well there are all these
parallel games that are going on inside
there
well it doesn't do you any good until
you can find out uh
something where you you can actually get
to the point where you have a definite
winner or loser
um
let's see
there's a question here
about um
from uh rushank about what do i think
about ai's writing mathematical proofs
and it says i read an article recently
about ai discovering the heliocentric
principle by itself
look the question is what are you trying
to do when you write a proof
a proof is is
in some ways an explanation of why
something is true
in order to write an explanation of why
something is true you have to know who
you're explaining it to
in other words there are proofs that
i've generated automatically
where yes the computer has has shown
that you go from this step to this step
to this step to this step
and another computer can easily verify
that those steps work but
the story of why this thing is true
computer absolutely doesn't tell us
and there's sort of a separate aish
problem
which is to take that set of steps that
the computer knows
will establish some results and to sort
of
arrange it so that it is a good human
narrative so people can understand what
was said
so for example in wolfman alpha we have
these step-by-step solutions and that's
exactly what we've done there we've made
it
using aish methods we've made it so that
it generates something which is a
reasonable
sort of human description of why the
particular problem comes out the way it
does
but that's a quite separate problem from
knowing
this is how the answer comes out now in
terms of discovering things from data
and so on
again it's really a question of what
kind of a story do you want to tell from
your data
in other words let's say you've got data
about
oh i don't know where the sun is as a
function of time
in um in the sky um you know what can
you conclude from that
you know can you find a simple model
consistent with
that with the path of the sun and so on
well uh that's something where again
it's very much a question of of the eye
of the beholder because
what counts as a simple model to someone
may not count as a simple model to
someone else
and when it comes to an ai discovering
that
it's like the air has to say look here
are some models that those humans
think are simple let me see if any of
those work for explaining the motion of
the sun
and absolutely you can do that um in
fact that's what statistics has been
about for a very long time
uh for 150 years or so now
we've kind of known how to take sort of
general classes of
of models and say well let's you know
let's see whether they
fit this particular thing that we
observe and using machine learning and
so on we can get a little bit more
general
about about what kind of model we use
but the trouble with that is
as soon as we're more general about the
kind of model we use there may be no
story about what that model means
so we can say yes this neural network it
found a way to reproduce the motion of
the sun
oh well it's got uh you know six million
numbers inside this thing uh do we know
what that means can we tell a story can
we say
that means the earth goes around the sun
uh no
that means that we've got a way to
reproduce
the motion of the of the sun in the in
the sky but it doesn't mean that we can
necessarily tell a sort of human-based
story for this so
it's a tricky thing asking the question
what
uh to what extent we can get kind of
automated
explanations the bigger part of that
question is
the explanation to us not the can you
fit the data fitting the data is easy
um particularly if you allow yourself
six million parameters or something
uh it's a question can we make a human
like uh
explanation of this
all right let me do one or two more and
then i've got to wrap up here
boy there's a question here from someone
texas tech
bringing high-end geospatial data
analytics
to the public in non-conventional
educational settings
i think the most significant thing i
would say here is is check out what we
do in mormon language with geospatial
data
it's really very nice and um uh
it allows one to kind of um
uh sort of it's you know what we try to
do a multi-language in general
is to um uh provide
a language which both humans and the
computer can understand so you know
there's a
you could just say um give me
the um you know use natural language to
say counties in texas or something
and then you'll get back some symbolic
representation of that
and you could say i don't know uh well
you could say what are the
uh you know what what some make
a geo list plot of those counties or
make a geo
region value plot where you say the
population of each county and you put
that in and that's all
stuff that you can do in a piece of
wolfram language
that is something that people can read
and that's
something that's really really
interesting because it's not
like uh sort of pandering to the low
level of what the computer wants to see
it's rather the sort of thing i've spent
oh
the last third of a century doing is
trying to make it so that
what one has is something that is sort
of clear enough
that it can be understood by humans as
well as by the computer
and we can represent all of these
geospatial kinds of things
really nicely at this kind of very high
level that's understandable to both both
humans and
machines and i i recommend looking at
that if you're if you're interested in a
specific place to look to get started
the book i wrote called elementary
introduction to wolfram language has a
has a section about um i forget what
it's called geographic
kinds of things um and that would be a
good place it's probably five or six
pages long that's a good place to start
um
let's see
um
all right i'll answer one more thing
here which is a
from noro what's the best way to learn
something for slow learners
i don't know exactly what a slow learner
is i kind of think it depends on what
you're trying to learn
there are things i've tried to learn
where i am a super slow learner
and there are things i've tried to learn
where i think i've learned it pretty
fast
i mean for example for me oh what's a
good example
um i don't know there are there are
probably a bunch of kind of
um um you know physical
skills about i'm not too uncoordinated
actually but but
um uh things like what's a good example
of something i've tried to learn
um
[Music]
uh tying a bow tie i'm my bow tie
i learned that when i was a kid who used
it about five times in adult life
um the uh but it's things like that
i am uh you know unbelievably slow
learner
when it comes to more abstract things uh
one
area i've been learning recently is a
very abstract area of mathematics called
category theory
and i've been really pretty slow at
learning that okay
here's the basic point that i found in
learning things
so you know i learn them relative to
things i already know
and there are
people so there are different styles of
learning so some people
can you can tell them a bunch of stuff
that they don't really understand
and they can kind of swim in that for a
while
and eventually they manage to start
anchoring things and then they
understand it
that's not usually the way i work i tend
to be
i have to build from something i already
know and little steps
where i really understand it all the way
down the line so to speak
it's a different people learn things
differently i mean i i
you know i certainly know people who
really do learn things by
you know first they swim in this kind of
soup and then start
they start to be able to attach to
things
in my case it's like i really need to
know step by step what's happening
for me also the sort of concreteness of
i you know i spent my life building
these tools to make this possible you
know i
i type some piece of code and something
happens and it does what i expect or it
doesn't do what i expect
concretifying what i'm thinking about
into
wolfram language code is really an
important step for me
that's what that's what allows me once
once i have it sort of concretely
as a piece of code that i can just run
and it does what i think it should do or
it doesn't do what i think it should do
then i really feel like i understand
something i would say also for me
explaining stuff is a really good way to
know whether i understand it that's why
i like doing these uh these
uh events every week um is this is an
opportunity for me to try to explain
stuff
and every time i explain something i
think i understand a little bit better
myself
so i would say that that um there are
different styles of learning things
but i think one question is do you sort
of
not learn something because you know
somebody's told you something
and then they say okay what's the answer
to this exercise and you're like i don't
have the slightest idea
um and uh because you kind of
you didn't really you know there wasn't
a series of steps you took where you
really understood each step you kind of
tried to jump
too far and you end up kind of drowning
in this kind of sea of
of things you don't understand um you
know as i say
for me at least i find it best to just
go
one small step at a time where where i'm
really understanding each step
and where if i don't understand the step
i keep grinding until i do understand
that step
um now it really helps to know about a
lot of other things
because the question is if you're taking
these small steps it's like where are
you starting from
well if you already know a whole bunch
of other stuff the
it's it's um uh that's really useful
because it gives you a starting point
it's like you know in learning category
theory
turns out knowing about i don't know uh
things about oh graph theory and things
like that where
i can just sort of take for granted i
know about that stuff so therefore
i can use it in this other place um i
think that
um uh you know another thing that is
often
um um what can i say perhaps down
downplayed in modern education is just
knowing facts is really useful
you know it's one thing to know
principles about how to do things but
you anchor that with just a bunch of
facts
um about all kinds of things and it's
amazing how often i'm using a fact about
something that i learned
in some areas i don't know learning
about something about physics
i'll use that fact in thinking about
something about computers or i'll use
that fact
about um i'm sure probably even today
and the things i've been talking about
here
uh you know it's it's like a lot of
things are anchored with facts
um and even knowing about historical
facts
uh for example getting some sense of how
difficult should it be to understand
this thing
was it something which took a thousand
years of human history before people
understood it
well then you might be excused for it
being a little difficult for you to
understand it
um or is it something where this was
actually pretty easy a pretty easy
step from something else well then you
know what was the other thing it was a
step from
you go back and you you try to
understand something from that
um so i think that the um uh you know
as i say people have different styles of
learning and and
for me in particular i'm a very concrete
learner at some level i mean i
i end up working on very abstract things
but i get to them in very concrete ways
in other words you know i've i've i've
worked on some very abstract ideas and
abstract principles and so on
but the way i got to them is i did
computer experiments i saw this i saw
that i saw the other thing
i made some connections between these
things and eventually i'm at this
you know high level about abstraction
but that high level of abstraction was
reached
in little small steps um always seeing
concretely what was going on
again not everybody works that way some
people i think
are capable of reasoning at this very
abstract level
intrinsically you know sometimes in my
perception
they can be like you know they can be
sort of living in the clouds and then
they realize
there's a long way to fall and there's
nothing holding them up so to speak
um and that can happen if you're sort of
operating at the sort of very abstract
level
without some foundation um to come from
but i think that's
some um uh and in terms of
you know i mean for example in terms of
learning things i you know i would
say that that i for example i'm a
learning by doing kind of person
so i well two things i need to be
motivated and i need to actually do
stuff
so whenever i've said i'm just going to
learn this thing for the sake of
learning it
i have a hard time with that um whenever
i'm like
well i'm supposed to be learning about
this i wonder about this question that
question the other question
okay let me learn these intermediate
steps because i care about this question
i'm trying to answer
even if that's something that you might
learn in school or something like that
if there's some kind of overarching this
is where we're trying to get to this is
what i'm curious about you know
if i'm learning about economics you know
what will happen
if you know the us government spends two
trillion dollars what consequences does
that have
you know does that mean you know
there'll be this that or the other how
do i understand enough economics in
between
to know the answer to that question um
and
uh you know so for me having motivating
questions is important
um i think that also for me actually
doing stuff like figuring out okay then
i'm gonna figure out if you do this you
do that
and i'm gonna figure out you know in um
uh the um you know i'm going to write a
little program that does this so that
i'm going to see what the result is
and i'm going to do stuff when it's just
me passively reading something i'm
i personally am really bad at that in
fact i'm
i'm almost shockingly bad you know i
have probably eight thousand nine
thousand books
i've looked through all of them but how
many of them have i actually
read you know page by page by page
depressingly few
um it's not the way that i best ingest
information
i i kind of look you know what's the
point okay can i figure out why that's
true
let me sort of do it for myself again
not everybody works that way
um and uh uh you know i think that
that's um but that's
in my particular case and and sometimes
what happens when you learn things for
me at least
you know i'm learning some new area and
for a long time it'll be like
every new thing i hear about it's like
oh my gosh another thing i didn't know
about that
oh my gosh i didn't know about that and
it's like i'm drowning in this area
right because it's like i i just can't
you know it's like
you know you just told me 100 new things
i didn't know and you know
i can't extrapolate from the things i
did know to all the things i'm being
told
but then for me at least there comes
this moment when it's like
yup i more or less get it and then it's
like okay all these pieces start to fit
together
and then it's like okay somebody tells
me a new thing it's like yeah i kind of
knew that
his heart fits into the things i already
knew i'm i'm
i'm i'm good here um you know that
that's the point at which i really feel
like i understand stuff
in which i you know the other question
is when you
do things do you make mistakes you know
what causes the mistakes you make
are the mistakes you make mistakes
because you just you know
you're doing a piece of math and you
lost that minus sign okay that's not a
very interesting kind of mistake
um or is the mistake because you
fundamentally didn't understand what an
earth is going on
um i remember yeah i could i could name
some amusing ones from my youth
of ones where i was like i don't know
how this works
i completely don't know what's going on
and um
uh you know it's where but one of the
things i think
i for example have gotten fairly good
and i think it's a useful skill
is to know when you know so to speak and
to know when you don't know and it's
like there are things where
i'll be doing stuff people will be
trying to convince me of something
you know for our company or whatever
else and it's like okay i get it i know
yes fine let's do that let's not do that
whatever
and then there are cases where it's like
i know i do not know
and i know i don't know you can say make
a decision do this do that
i know i do not know and and then you
have to go try and figure it out
but that's an important way to avoid
making mistakes is to know when you
don't know
now you know if you're told this is a
timed exam you've got to write down a
bunch of answers on it
and this amount of time that's kind of a
goofy exercise in my opinion but but
um uh you know given that you're going
to do that well you do the best you can
do i don't know what the right solution
is i think i'm
i think i'm profoundly bad at those
things you know i the last time i did
some kind of
um exam like thing was probably when i
was
16 years old which is a depressingly
long time ago now
and that was before the days of multiple
choice so i didn't
um all the stuff um uh you know
that i hear from people my wife happens
to be one of these people who's really
good at sort of figuring out
how to kind of figure out well that
answer can't
be right and that one can't be right and
this one was this and this one was this
therefore it must be
c and um i just i never developed that
that set of skills for sort of gaming
those kinds of systems
um the uh in any case the
i think that that um um uh you know this
this question of
of uh you know when you do a lot of
kinds of things to me
it's important to not make mistakes if i
can avoid it and a huge
mechanism for not making mistakes is to
know when you don't know
another thing is to know the types of
mistakes you make like when i write
stuff
i leave words out that is my my disease
of writing
is i write a little bit fast you know i
think a little bit faster than i write
and um i just leave words out and i have
to go back and i'm pretty good at
proofreading my own stuff
but it's like i know i leave words out
so i have to
you know go through and like are all the
words there um
and and you know when i write code i
have long ago
learnt the types of mistakes i make so
that means it's really quite fast for me
to like i
you know i know kind of a catalog of
things that i do wrong
and that gradually allows me if
something's gone wrong it's like oh okay
try these you know
this might be the things i've done wrong
so those are those are a few suggestions
i suppose about some
uh um about learning things and i i
think come
um you know in um
um it's funny because there are things
which i learn where it might look
and feels to me like i'm a super slow
learner and there are
other things even the same thing later
on it's like there'll be a period where
i'm just
unbelievably slow and i don't understand
anything and then okay
i get it and then zoom one's off and
running
and you know then then then sometimes i
can be pretty fast even compared
to people have been working on those
things for decades and that's that's
always fun
um and you know honestly the main
advantage that i tend to have is just
i know a lot of stuff and that means
it's easier
to you know making connections between
things and using
some fact from somewhere to make a
conclusion about something else
that's um that's a really powerful thing
to do
all right i should wrap up here thanks
for lots of interesting questions once
again
um and the ones that i didn't get to
this week uh will store up
and potentially uh use next week
so um thanks very much and bye